herzlich willkommen liebe zuschauer zur
letzten heute show des jahres
beziehungsweise kenner der sendung
wissen dass zur traditionellen
verleihung des goldenen vollpfosten 2018
und ich schlage vor den ersten raum wir
gleich mal ohne vorrede raus er geht
aus aktuellem anlass und hochverdient an
großbritannien
die verwirrte insel der welt ja ich weiß
nicht wie es ihnen geht ich kann nur
sagen es ist nicht mehr auszuhalten
inzwischen wissen die briten gar nicht
mehr was sie wollen entscheidet euch mal
oder wie ihr sagen würde es sich bei die
fische jetzt mal ehrlich sieh mal
zusammen jetzt hat theresa may in nur
einer woche die abstimmung über den deal
mit der eu verschoben ein
misstrauensvotum überlebt und sie waren
noch auf betteltour in europa hier
symptomatische bilder aus berlin may
kommt einfach nicht mehr raus weder aus
der eu aus ihrem blöden auto kann man
erklären ist ein mercedes der hat eine
engländer sicherung
das ist einfach nur wegen der sicherheit
zweieinhalb jahre
zweieinhalb jahre hat die eu mit denen
verhandelt wahrscheinlich alles für die
tonne kann doch nicht wahr sein
ganz ehrlich ich weiß das klingt jetzt
hart aber man möchte den briten einfach
nur noch zurufen geht einfach ehrlich
geht einfach
oder vater drechselt weicher braig sind
flüssiger praxis das ist mir völlig egal
es ist mir inzwischen egal laut einer
studie der grossbank ubs ist die
britische wirtschaft jetzt schon zwei
prozent kleiner als sie ohne braig sind
chaos wäre das funktioniert weiter ab
trotzdem machen sie fröhlich weiter man
muss doch mal lernen aus seinen fehlern
das heer als ob weiß ich nicht england
einmal auf die heiße herdplatte fast
dann noch mal und dann noch anfängt sich
zusätzlich negativ ins auge zu stechen
es ist doch krank
ja bin kein arzt aber für mich hat das
was von masochismus
und genau dafür gibt es von uns meine
damen und herren heute denen ihr braucht
echt professionelle hilfe vollpfosten
und zwar in der zwangsjacken edition
aber mit allen guten wünschen für die
zukunft eures weltreiches so und damit
kommen wir auch schon nahtlos zu unserem
eigenen weltreich deutschlands
regierungspartei numero uno die cdu
wissen sie weshalb wird seit genau einer
woche
von annegret kramp karrenbauer geführt
lustig dass ich mich vorher versprochen
habe ja zur großen erleichterung der
kanzlerin hat die ak das gemacht haben
die sich gefreut die mädels oder
wahnsinn
ich wette ich wette ak hat ihren sieg
tierisch gefeiert als die letzte woche
wieder zu hause war oder wie feiert man
im saarland
[Musik]
jeder freut sich anders kakas triumph
wirklich schön für frau merkel aber und
das dürfen wir nie vergessen meine damen
und herren natürlich ein alptraum
und zwar für die ganze namen reporter
aus dem ausland annegret kramp
karrenbauer krenn.com gern eine andere
kultur zu land wo kamen bord
ja schön dass sie lachen aber die
chinesin liegt seitdem mit stirnband
buch auf der intensivstation und die
fans von friedrich merz leiden auch seit
einer woche ist auch klar das idol der
wirtschaftsverbände das idol unserer
leistungsträger am ende ganz knapp
gescheitert im finale von germany's next
topmodel 19 stimmen zu wenig hatte er
der märz es wird spekuliert vielleicht
vielleicht lag's an seiner rede die war
an manchen stellen merkwürdig
unpersönlich und an anderen ja latent
größenwahnsinnig und sie wissen
vermutlich ich bin wirklich ein freund
amerikas aber die amerikaner brauchen
hin und wieder eine klare und eindeutige
ansage absolut unsere bundeswehr hat
noch genau zwei funktionierende panzer
und ein klapprad aber wir machen den
amerikanern ansage klar so durchaus
spannende frage droht der cdu jetzt doch
langfristig eine spaltung oder eine
austrittswelle
um das zu verhindern hat annegret kramp
karrenbauer dem blutjungen und
erzkonservativen paul zehn jahren ist
kein witz während einer cdu partie auf
der tanzfläche gefragt ob er ihr
generalsekretär sein will
was soll da sagen was
was soll der arme junge da sagen da ist
ja auch angst im spiel wir halten fest
auf den letzten metern hat sich die
bundeskanzlerin
diesmal in gestalt von annegret kramp
karrenbauer doch noch mal durchgesetzt
wahnsinn müsste man eigentlich verfilmen
man nannte sie black widow denn sie hat
sie alle aus dem weg geräumt
[Musik]
diese arme sau sogar gleich zwei mal
ganz genau
sie hat ihren eigenen cloner die
parteien spitze gehievt und damit
bleiben noch genau zwei gegner magneto
und professor fix denn es kann nur eine
geben
ja
sie hat
kurz vor schluss da muss man so sagen
der letzte freitag schon wieder ein
schwerer rückschlag für die männer in
der cdu nach 18 jahren merkel direkt die
nächste frau entspricht das wirklich dem
leistungsprinzip oder wird unser
geschlecht in der union doch
systematisch benachteiligt
reden wir drüber mit birte schneider
männer beauftragte der heute show wird
er jetzt mal ganz hat nachgefragt haben
männer überhaupt noch eine perspektive
in dieser cdu ja ohne war ich sags ganz
ehrlich ich bin ja jetzt auch ein stück
weit ratlos und enttäuscht ich dachte
wir wären als gesellschaft schon weiter
gerade jetzt muss man junge männer
ermutigen und sagen hey ihr könnt alles
werden also herzlich cdu vorsitzende
aber es gibt so viele berufe die auf
euch zugeschnitten sind berufe weiß ich
nicht wo man schwere sachen tragen muss
gerüstbauer eisenbieger hufschmied sowas
und das ist ermutigend weil ja klar ich
sage mal männer können fast alles was
frauen können außer gut verlieren
das hat man letzten freitag leider
wieder gesehen manager kriegt eure mimik
einfach nicht unter kontrolle hier
freudentränen bei annegret fritze
guckten hin wenns donnert und schäuble
dabei ist die annegret eigentlich
konservativer als märz um sparen
zusammen erzkatholisch gegen die kurie
für härteres abschieben aber unterm
strich bleibt eine frau und da sagt ein
schäuble hals
ich verstehe den frust der wolle hatte
den sieg von merz seit monaten geplant
mit seinen kumpels oettinger und roland
koch vom sogenannten andenpakt der
angepackt diese maskulinen merke gegner
die damals zusammen in südamerika
gewandert sind ja genau die berühmte cdu
krötenwanderung ein männerbund der jetzt
schon wieder gedemütigt wird um die
verdiente rache betrogen von einer ein
meter 48 großen saarländerin deutlich
weist die bitte das bild das sie hier
vom mann an sich zeichnen gefällt mir
aber auch nicht
tschuldigung ich kämpfe seit jahren für
männer rechte viele meiner freunde sind
männer
mein freund auf tatsächlich ist das
klassische alphamännchen inzwischen eine
bedrohte art wer setzt sich denn heute
noch breitbeinigen talkshows kratzt sich
am sack und redet herablassend über
frauen
wolfgang kubicki
ich habe ihre rede gehört rhetorisches
beachtlich und auch emotional sehr gut
vorgetragen hatte ich hätte ich ihnen so
nicht zugetraut
als wenn ich schlecht gemacht händchen
für mädchen sommer hier warum schickst
du dir nicht mal ein bisschen könnte es
gar nicht schlecht aussehen naja die
silberrücken lecken sich jetzt noch kurz
ihre wundern ist das abgehakt
der war gut was da gerade alles an
verschwörungstheorien zur märz
niederlage durch durchs netz geistert es
gab geheime absprachen zwischen a kk und
sparen klar und meine lieblings ausrede
jemand hat bei der rede von merz das
mikro leiser gestellt
ich dachte mir hat einfach nur eine
chance rede gehalten
aber nein das mikro war schuld deswegen
liebe zuschauer verleiht die heute-show
dem cdu an den pakt nach diesem schweren
schlag für das männliche ego den
goldenen vollpfosten in der mikro penis
edition
[Applaus]
[Musik]